Harvard University researchers say last
year's death toll from Hurricane Maria
is dramatically larger than reported the
study published in the New England
Journal of Medicine estimates more than
4600 people died in Puerto Rico the
official government death toll is just
64 David beg no has reported extensively
more from Puerto Rico on the hurricane
he's back in San Juan this morning David
good morning John good morning we're in
one of the body azar districts here in
San Juan where researchers randomly went
door to door knocked and asked if anyone
died here there were more questions than
that but that's how it got started with
a $50,000 grant from Harvard six weeks
worth of work and a headline on a death
toll that his stunned people Puerto
Rico's governor Ricardo Roe say yo who
himself as a scientist seemed blindsided
by the Harvard study the protocol is
that doctors tell the government if a
death was caused by Hurricane Maria
families have to petition the government
to investigate if they disagree with the
doctors opinion those brown dots show
where the Harvard study researchers
surveyed more than three thousand homes
around the island and found the
mortality rate rose 62 percent in the
three months after Hurricane Maria
compared to that period the year before
researchers concluded the final death
count could be as high as 8,500 Domingo
Marquez was a lead author on the study
what was the majority reason people died
after the storm and related to the storm
one-third of our deaths were reported
because of lack of medical treatment we
saved a lot of lives during his visit to
Puerto Rico last October
president Trump hailed the low death
toll which at the time was 16 you can be
very proud of all of your people all of
our people in light of the Harvard
report a White House spokesperson said
the people of Puerto Rico deserve
nothing less than transparency and
accountability the negligence that
allowed those lives to be lost
needs to be accounted for San Juan Mayor
Carmen you lean crews has blasted mr.
Trump for being tone-deaf and slow to
respond when asked to evaluate her own
response she said I know I didn't get to
everyone we did the best we could but
that wasn't good enough
here's why this story is about more than
just a shocking number every time a
government official certifies that a
death has been directly related to
Hurricane Maria the family of the person
who died is then eligible for the
federal government to help pay for
funeral expenses Gail that's why these
numbers are so important and you said it
best are also very shocking and painful
to hear thank you very much David beg No
reporting from Puerto Rico once again